[Music]
you should do this because the products
are not the variable of success the
knowledge of understanding how to
communicate this you got your
prospective be happy don't you want to
be happy
[Music]
somebody was crying this morning I was
on Twitter they're like [ __ ]
Instagram not getting the reach anymore
us artists we're getting [ __ ] can't
get as many people seeing it now they
want us to pay [ __ ] [ __ ]
Facebook and Instagram I'd apply them
like shits free I'm like what do you
mean they're taking away your [ __ ] it
was it's free then I call I didn't think
about it that way here's the biggest
thing about that the only people that
are listening to you are other losing
players your honor the only other people
that are co-signing your excuses are
other losers always have I always take
them on my future every day like I know
a lot people say oh don't think so far
to the future but should I have to
because I want to see where my self is
like 5 or 10 years from now like my beep
I thought real quick being thoughtful
about the future is amazing but not
letting it [ __ ] you as the key yeah
cuz my problem yeah I would think so
first in the future I was started
worrying about stuff yep I want to
accomplish before I leave this earth
years from now that I want to do like oh
it's great to have ambition yeah yeah
that's when if you cast too much
judgement on yourself on a day to day on
how you're reaching that ambition
you're gonna [ __ ] yourself but the
fact that you understand that that is
your perspective means you're on the
cusp of fixing it only thing that I've
ever seen really work in this scenario
where your DNA and your experiences has
made you look half glass full
pessimistic versus optimistically blind
is to fundamentally surround yourself
with optimistic people you got a cut out
pessimistic in negativity and you got to
add on optimism and positivity it's as
simple as that you guys should be
looking around at each other and whoever
else is in here and like in order who's
the most optimist and not don't there's
a real fine line between delusion and
optimism I'm gonna be in the league but
they're not even practicing
so that's delusion I'm gonna be in a
league and maybe you don't see it but
you see them at least doing free throws
5 a.m. to 6 a.m. every morning before
they go on the bus you know Lisa's
trying Aniston and the more difficult
your circumstances are the more likely
you're around pessimism that my number
one piece of advice of leaving here is
here become more friendly with them
[Laughter]
that's one of my favorite clips ever
just like watching your we'r right there
just your eyes it's the best man it
feels so good it's so it's so real like
that advice I give you is real my belief
is that if you're a great drug dealer
you'd be a great businessman I just
believe that because it's the same game
there's a lot of drug dealers that suck
at it
look at my man mousse he's breaking down
these bags and some nickels because he's
making more money that way and he's
chanting he's actually making $3 bags
but he realized that everybody at the
school doesn't know the [ __ ]
difference doesn't care he's smart so if
you're good at it or if somebody's if
somebody's good at it they'd be even
better at flipping sneakers or gear or
go into the thrift store and flipping
because it's the same [ __ ] move and
then when you have the freedom of being
not scared to get caught now you're
[ __ ] moving fast now you're a [ __ ]
entrepreneur and everybody thinks you
know like people putting you on a
pedestal
hello in top-line revenue yes
sales cool I don't care I'm basic as
[ __ ] do you know how many Harvard
Business School people have ever built a
business doing 2.5 million a lot less
than you think so so I promise you
you're not basic the amount of humans
that have walked around that do 2.5
million in sales is low I mean it and
the second you understand that in the
same way with him like we're gonna just
like this is real that's why I'm like
pump this is why I love like how the
world evolved it's much more for like
that's real yeah well yeah that's for
sure but it's not predicated because you
didn't go to business school or you
don't know the turn I still don't know
all the terms you ready for this I think
I googled them first seven years ago
like like like my mom and sister always
up they're like where the [ __ ] did your
vocab come from I'm like osmosis you
know comfortable yeah what's your what's
your gut tell you it's starting to not
gonna work soon like what's your gut
tell you you're leaving too much on the
table
avoiding actually pushing myself and
like doing something that I'm afraid to
do because I'm sticking to like what has
proven to be our way positive yes yes
well do you want to build something that
is seven million
you sure yes okay okay it's not
aggressive but just arbitrary you should
definitely do that okay no no because
you need to know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about your business I've
consistently stayed consistent on this
which is if you don't know the craft
how are you judging the people you're
hiring that's different
sure everything else you doing you
should give away good
I just contextualized it for you how are
you gonna find those seven hours a day
to get great at social you're doing
something now I assume whychus on
autopilot I got it so what are you doing
well good you should do this because the
products are not the variable of success
the knowledge of understanding how to
communicate to the end consumer are
there's nothing more important than mean
close to the end consumer nothing else
matters there's another big thing that's
gonna happen you're gonna make a
thousand way better products after
you're done with this because you're
gonna be in the trenches yeah and not in
a [ __ ] siloed ivory tower you're
gonna have much better intuition on the
product we're not trying to be Walmart
you have a really awesome high quality
high design products and our value
proposition is just so much more but how
would you think about I I think you
always have to listen to your customers
but your customers are always gonna say
that listen and synthesize and make
decisions right like that's why both
listening to your customers to develop
product is right and also whoever said
if I listen to my customers I would have
made a faster horses right they both can
work it's Big Data people love to talk
about big data big data is very cute
what you do with the data is what
matters
you could stay the course and keep your
brand affinity in the right place and
win you could lower your price and that
was exactly right it was a ten percent
swing that totally changed of course in
your business you could lower your price
by 10% nothing different happened and
now you've just given up 10% margin and
maybe even hurt a little brand equity
they've all worked listening and then
the beauty of business business is
talent how many of those people have you
called because I'll tell you what I'm
good at and I don't know you - it's one
thing to read it it's another thing to
hear it so maybe you take a you know
maybe you take 50 of those people and
you actually call them and you put in
those 50 hours or those 25 hours on 50
people and then you say okay now I've
heard it the full [ __ ] amount right or
I've heard it [ __ ] there's something I
believe as leadership there's something
there that's it
there's no right it's contextual but
you're listening which is huge hey guys
thank you so much for watching my video
on YouTube I wanted to jump in here at
the end because I'm working on a
ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help
if you drink wine at all or know anybody
that drinks wine at all please go to
empathy wines calm right now and sign up
for a subscription whether it's a three
pack whether it's a six pack or whether
it's a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for club empathy this
project means the world to me that could
really use your support
[Music]